you were married to an american you find
another american
and now you're having a baby with
another american
ariela's mom got straight to the
elephant in the room
and she didn't stop until she got
answers i mean is your plan to come to
the united states
hey my 90 day fans fam it's melisia
the latest episode of the other way was
all about
telling the truth and for those who got
caught in their lives
this just might be the end i'm going to
update you on the couples who
struggled the most kicking things off
with ariella and baby
aka benyam i have a lot of confusion
about what happened with your first wife
and how she just left
even me i'm confused why she
she divorced me you should find a
message like
the girls someone is my old friend
then she's not happy with us
i'm confused she thought you were
talking to other women
yeah and she didn't like that i tell her
i'm sorry i'm sorry for everything
binium thought that ariela's mom would
go for that story
but at this point she is looking for
reasons to take
ariella back with her to the states so
she continued to press him
but wait tell me you're sorry you didn't
do anything wrong no you said
my mom can be intimidating she doesn't
have a lot of patience
and talking with video in english
requires a lot of patience
i didn't draw anything i didn't do
anything but she left and then she
she blocked me well did she have a
reason
no jesus there was no reason but don't
you wonder what happened
ariella is chalking it up to her mom
being intimidating
and the language barrier but it seems as
if binium is at a loss for words because
he just isn't telling the entire truth
if you ask me
ariella should be trying to get answers
as well
i mean is your plan to come to the
united states
so what's your plan with arie
uh yeah we need to do anything like
gustas
okay so that's the next question yeah so
now this is gonna cost money
you know if you get a regular apartment
and you don't live in squalor
i'm working like right and like my job
like dancing
then i would start like singing oh yeah
you didn't forget right
bingham is a music artist and he goes by
the name
baby cool don't say don't say
don't say don't say baby cool ariella
definitely started to show the concern
her mother has had all along after
bennion revealed
how he plans to take care of her and the
baby what do you think connie are you
okay you're so quiet to me today
yeah i don't know i think i'm feeling
overwhelmed and realizing we haven't
established ourselves we're not really
sure what we need to spend money on
you're going to be calling me and dad if
you need something i'm worried that a
lot of the financial burden won't fall
on me
i support myself mainly doing freelance
writing and editing
and the last thing i want to do is be
dependent upon my parents
after their conversation ariella's mom
made it very clear
she's not leaving ethiopia until she
knows
that ariella and the baby will be okay
speaking of leaving
devin is pretty much throwing in the
towel when it comes to her relationship
with ji hoon
after meeting up with him and his
parents for dinner the translator that
they use
combined with jihoon's guilty feelings
turned what could have been an
opportunity for understanding into
chaos
i'll make another mistake i'll waste
that money again
translator getting worst
situation i apologize for this island
and i'm so sorry and the birds have
changed
yeah i'm so sorry i'm getting very mad
oh translators so piss off and
here comes the meltdown i need you guys
[Music]
it's very frustrating that g him is not
translating anything
he's just yelling so to see him lose his
temper like this it's just disgusting
the situation got even worse after
jihoon's mom laughed when devin was
expressing how much
pain jihoon has caused her my life is
ruined now
this isn't a joke i don't want to do
this they think it's a joke
i don't want to do this i don't want to
do this anymore
for once i'm with ji hoon on this one
devin i think it's time to head back to
america
well next week on the other way after
they visited the hospital
and everything checked out ariela and
binyum run into
a new issue to deal with on top of their
living conditions
and that issue is other women
who is this person he's dancing with his
ex-girlfriend
gotta watch out here especially when he
stands in that night in her home alone
all right 90 day fans fam we want to
make sure you stay updated on
all the latest news from the 90 day
universe
so make sure you stick with e.t because
we are covering it all
see you next time
[Music]